Okay since it's trending now
So for everyone's information
There is such a graph and which
We can see
If the frequency of the earth increases
And this past few days
The frequency really shot up
And it was recorded to be
The highest it has ever been which is such a good news
And i'll tell you why later
Um the more
That's because the frequency of the earth is increasing
It means we are approaching the new earth
You'll notice now more and more people
They are shifting into an elevated level of consciousness
Our old life is starting to collapse
In preparation to enter our new reality
So why does it sound like it's such a big thing
Cause firstly it really is a big thing
Dolores Canon
New Earth has been talking about for years now and
He's actually a pretty long topic and is'll try to
Search for videos
That explains the concept of New Earth
And is trying to post it here for you to watch
So going back
Because that means
When the frequency of the earth increases
It means that many people have spent the weekends
And if the past few days
You can feel symptoms like this
Don't worry about its cause
That's normal
So normally we have dna
Upgrades or dereleases the toxins in our body
It may be
Toxic people
Toxic environment
Or substances that don't serve or are the highest good
And during this time you will have experiences
People who will fall off your life
It's because
They no longer resonate with your new frequency
Or you have an experience perging like for example
Some relationships will end or someone will lose their job
I'm not trying to be negative ha
Always look at the bigger picture
Because there is no coincidence
And one more thing
That everyone will experience this shift
So if you've been feeling the effects recently
Or you've been going through a tough time now
Just hang in there
Just continue racing your vibration
And do your shadow work
And you promise
Everything will fall into place